joining us now is a former white house
press secretary co-host of outnumbered
and author of a brand new book for such
a time
as this which comes out tuesday kaylee
mcinerney kaylee i want to ask you about
your book because my mom and my wife are
going to be proud i think that comes
from the bible i think the title comes
from the bible esther 4 14 yes
okay if i'm right my mom and my wife are
going to be shocked and very very happy
but before
we get to that i don't mind tough
questions i just want them to be asked
of both sides with the same frequency
what was your experience
it was not that look i went in
and tried to clear my mind of what i
knew about the media because i came from
the campaign i already knew the media
was not fair i agree with the 56 percent
of americans who believe that
journalists actively make up stories to
fit their narrative that's 56 percent
that's high however i wanted a reset so
i went in tried to have a clean slate
however the questions became very
caustic very quickly very personal
you contrast that to some of the
questions currently being asked of jin
saki she's been asked about a biting
incident with the white house dog she's
been asked about the white house cat
she's been asked about the air force one
color scheme these are questions that
don't serve the american people these
are questions i was never asked
ultimately i think a fair press is
somewhere between the softballs jinsaki
gets the tough questions i got somewhere
in between or their substantive
questions for the american people
all right you're a smart person so i
like to ask why
why is there this perception and or
reality that one side gets tougher
questions i mean i i think whether
people like jonathan swan or not
he seems to be a pretty uh equal
opportunity tough questioner lay him
aside that was not my experience when i
was in congress
republicans get much tougher questions
than democrats
but the but the question is then why why
do you think that is
well i mean when you look at the the
donations of journalists at a lot of
these publications who they've given to
if they do give to a political candidate
it always is democrat over republican uh
this is a media that has a liberal bent
they exist in the confines of manhattan
largely in the d.c swamp so they very
rarely get outside the bubble where you
know i had the pleasure of getting to
know trump voters all across the country
from iowa to texas to florida to new
hampshire and i got to hear what people
were saying on the ground but very few
reporters at the height of media get
that that opportunity so it's a liberal
profession unfortunately the questions
don't serve the american people and you
know i hope it changes but we need young
people to go into journalism like
jonathan swann i agree or steve holland
or some of the others who are equal
opportunist questioners
all right you have a new book out um you
which means you have
written more books than i have read you
may have written more than one but i
know you got a new one coming out for
such a time as this
tell us what motivated and inspired you
and what we will learn as we read it
well you know i'm a person of faith i'm
a christian and throughout the hard
times in life and certainly there were
hard times in the white house
my savior showed up and you know i
wanted to talk about my faith journey
from a young person all the way through
the white house but in addition to that
and just kind of my personal memoir i do
get into the press there's a whole
chapter called vindication there were so
many narratives trey we know now not to
be true that president trump gassed and
pummeled protesters to hold a bible up
in front of saint john's church specter
general found that that wasn't true
there were many others russian bounties
on the heads of american troops in
afghanistan again that was not true so
we hold the press accountable in my book
but also more importantly and most
importantly i share about my my faith in
my lord and savior and how he showed up
when the going got tough
all right let me ask you this we've got
about 30 seconds and it may require you
more
the challenge of someone who's a
believer like you
to be in the environment that you were
in um did it strengthen your faith or
weaken your faith
oh it strengthened it there were a lot
of tears especially before i first took
to the podium i was very nervous um but
when you're in those valleys in life
that is when that god shows up and i
heard from him through the prayers of
many um through people on the left and
the right who would send me the same
bible verse for such a time as this i
heard that twice and sometimes when
there's duplication
god's telling you something for a reason
hence the title of my book
for such a time as this uh caitlin
mcinerney thank you for your service to
our country and thank you for joining us
tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else